[MUSIC PLAYING]
CATHY PEARL: Even though I
think the world has woken up
a bit more to the fact
that women really are here
and we are ready to be more
involved and ready to have
a bigger part, it hasn't
all changed overnight.
And so it's wonderful to see
an event like this where you're
surrounded by all these
inspiring and powerful women
who are not afraid to
say yes, I am doing
great interesting
things, and to remind us
that, even though sometimes
maybe at work or out
in the world, you feel like
you're in the minority,
it's so nice to be surrounded
by these women who are facing
similar things and realize that
more and more people are really
waking up to this and trying
to do something about it.
Voice technology is
accessible in the sense
that you can build on a
platform like Google Assistant,
anyone is allowed
to build on it,
and publish an action that
the whole world can use.
And so, if you can learn how
to do the necessary coding
and design, you can
create these things
and put them out in the world
and anybody can use them.
And it's, to me, a very
kind of equalizing way
to get this
technology out there.
Part of my job is
to let people know
that there is this thing
called conversation design.
It's a design discipline that
should be applied anytime
you're building a voice
or conversational thing,
whether it's on the Google
Assistant or anywhere.
And the point of
it is to say that,
no matter what
you're building, you
have to think about who
is the person using it.
And you have to apply these
principles of conversation.
Just like humans have
rules about how we talk,
we have to take those rules and
apply them to the technology
that we have today.
I think that first moment
when you have that first back
and forth where it's speaking
and you're talking back
is a super pivotal exciting
moment where your brain kind
of goes, wait a minute.
And it starts opening up
all these possibilities
and ideas of things you can do.
SHARMISHTHA GUPTA: Plugging
all my gadgets in my house
with that in there, and just
to come out and not even worry
about I have to get up from
couch and press that button.
Maybe I shouldn't even
without the Google Assistant.
Good learning, I think
I can do that now.
DOLIMER RODRIGUEZ: So I'm
here to brainstorm, get ideas,
be inspired for my work,
but also for myself as well.
Working with Actions
on Google, I'm
really looking forward to
keeping my mother actually
in mind.
So Google Assistant obviously
is creating access to folks
to just streamline
work in a lot of ways.
And my mother who is an
immigrant from the Dominican
Republic into the United
States, just thinking of her
and how I can make something
more accessible to her.
She has access to a phone.
However, she doesn't
really have much access
to the applications and the
ease the applications can bring
due to the language barrier.
And also the
knowledge barrier when
it comes to working
with technology
and how fast it's
becoming so innovative.
So, yeah, I'm looking
forward to creating
something that will benefit
her and many women who
also are experiencing some pull
back from technology like she
is.
HANNAH LUXENBERG: So I
went to the tech workshop
where we programmed
the Google Assistant.
And I have been
learning to program.
I decided to dive into
the technical workshop,
even though I'm
really not that great.
I thought that they
were all going to be
pro coders walking in there.
And it turns out that we were
kind of all in the same boat
and helping each other out.
SHARMISHTHA GUPTA: So
I read the description
before I came to
the workshop that
described that it is
a little bit related
to NLP on how you would
understand the language itself.
I have never worked with the
application myself previously,
but it's definitely
an interesting space
where it's growing.
The workshop was well
documented online.
I had fun doing it.
And I think I'll
definitely continue on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]